CHECKS ARE NECESSARY TO STOP
MASS SHOOTINGS.
MEANWHILE, THE STORY WE BROUGHT
YOU.
JUSTICE IS ON THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT WILL DECIDE
WHETHER A CROSS ON PUBLIC LAND
IN MARYLAND CONSTITUTES AN
ILLEGAL ENDORSEMENT OF RELIGION
BY THE GOVERNMENT.
FOX NEWS CHIEF CORRESPONDENT AND
ANCHOR OF FOX NEWS ADVICE
SHANNON BREAM TELLS US ABOUT THE
DAY'S ARGUMENTS.
>> IT SADDENS ME TO BE HERE
STANDING BEFORE YOU.
>> VETERANS FROM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY SHOWED UP AT THE PER
SUPREME COURT TODAY SUPPORTING A
WORLD WAR I MEMORIAL IN THE
SHAPE OF A CROSS.
IT WAS BUILT WITH PRIVATE FUNDS
IN AN EFFORT HEADED BY THE
AMERICAN LEGION A CENTURY AGO.
AND HE AND HIS GROUP HAS SPENT
YEARS FIGHTING TO GET RID OF THE
CROSS IN MARYLAND WHICH
ORIGINALLY SAT ON A PLOT OF
PRIVATE LAND THAT HAS SINCE BEEN
TRANSFERRED TO GOVERNMENT
OWNERSHIP.
CRITICS SAY THE ENTANGLEMENT OF
GOVERNMENT AND RELIGION IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL WHILE ADVOCATES
OF THE PEACE CROSS SAY IT'S A
SECULAR WAR MEMORIAL.
TODAY, JUSTICE KAGAN SAY MANY
SEE IT AS MUCH MORE.
"IT'S THE FOREMOST SYMBOL OF
CHRISTIANITY, ISN'T IT?
IT INVOKES THE CENTRAL
THEOLOGICAL CLAIM OF
CHRISTIANITY THAT JESUS THE SON
OF GOD DIED ON THE CROSS."
IT ARGUES THAT THIS SENDS A
MESSAGE OF ENDORSEMENT TO --
JUSTICE ALITO ASKED ABOUT THE
ALTERNATIVE, OTHER POTENTIAL
MONUMENTS, SAYING THAT YOU'VE
GOT TO TAKE DOWN ALL OF THE
CROSSES.
WHAT MESSAGE DOES THAT SAID WHEN
PEOPLE SEE IT ON TV?
THEY SEE CROSSES ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY BEING KNOCKED DOWN?
THE STEEL BEAMS LEFT BEHIND IN
THE WAKE OF 9/11 WHICH MANY
VIEWED AS A CROSS LIGHT SYMBOL
GOT A LOT OF ATTENTIONS FROM THE
JUSTICES, PROVOKING ATTENTION
OF WHERE THE COURT SHOULD DRAW
THE LINE IN GOVERNMENT INVOLVED
DISPLAYS INVOLVING RELIGIOUS
IMAGERY.
JUSTICE GORSUCH SAID THIS IS ONE
OF THE ONLY SITUATIONS WHERE
PEOPLE ARE ALLOWED TO SUE OVER
SOMETHING LIKE THIS BECAUSE IT
OFFENDS THEM, ADDING THAT WE'VE
GOT TO FIND A WAY TO TOLERATE